far left activists making good on their
promise for a night of Rage after
rampaging through downtown Atlanta for
an anti-police protest they set a cop
car on fire smashed Windows spray
painted buildings and trash businesses
police say some even had explosive
devices six people have been arrested
seen here smiling or stone-faced in
their mug shots and they're now facing
domestic charges of domestic terrorism
that's a felony that could lead to
Serious jail time the violence is the
culmination of months of fighting over a
proposed police training center so last
week police tried to clear protesters
from that area when one of the activists
shot and wounded a Georgia State Trooper
police returned fire and killed that
suspect
the chaos has the city on edge but the
media does not seem to agree
I think that there's a real blurring of
the lines in the use of the word
violence
is property destruction violence
um to some people it certainly is to
keep using these words violent violent
violent violent the only acts of
violence against people that I saw were
actually police tackling protesters but
the mayor of Atlanta and its police
chief are pushing back against that
particular claim
the crimes range from violence to
domestic terrorism to assault battery
and some other things but yes it is
violent when someone turns to burn down
a police car or break out windows or
have explosives on them it doesn't take
a rocket scientist or an attorney to
tell you that breaking windows and
setting fires out protest that is
Terrorism and that they will be charged
accordingly and they will find that this
police department and the partnership is
equally committed to stop that activity
Greg isn't it strange that a media's
Instinct would be to not defend the
mayor or the police chief in this
situation in a big city yeah I just wish
we had evidence of violence because I
clearly didn't see anything there that
warranted calling these people violent
extremists I don't know where you guys
get this stuff I'm just really really
saddened what happened to the new Leaf
that CNN was going to turn over right I
mean this is kind of like it's kind of
like Will Smith being returning to the
Oscars and then slapping somebody they
they spent three years being ridiculed
for downplaying violence right CNN
mostly peaceful blah blah blah then they
have I I just imagine the producers when
they had that guy on there were going oh
my God I can't believe we're doing this
again
we swore we were never going to say
mostly peaceful we swore we weren't
going to like be apologists for Terror
and then it happens and there they are
it is interesting though you have to ask
yourself why do people say these things
and
when it so clearly goes against the
things that you see and it happens all
the time and it's ideology this is the
perfect example ideology is designed to
cause people to deny reality right it's
there in front of you these people are
committing acts of violence that you say
it's not happening that is because it
doesn't jive with your reality your
ideology
the ideology that you agree with so it's
really personal so when you see this
happening you have to deny it and then
you look at the people that are and you
wonder like how is antifa still here and
you have to remember they were elevated
they were elevated by the media they
were approved because they were
anti-fascists who's to say protests
can't be violent the famous Cuomo line
CNN had a way of picking the losers you
know they picked antifa they picked uh
what's that terrible lawyer avenatti
they picked uh it's malat they pick
Andrew Cuomo everybody that they seem to
say is you know good ends up bad and a
lot of I think I think all of those that
were arrested were not from even from
Georgia let alone Atlanta judge and they
and the police you said they are going
to be charged yeah as well they should
be and you know it's interesting Greg
when you talked about ideologies you
said my ideology and their ideology and
the one word you didn't use was reality
because it's not about reality anymore
it's about ideologies they decide
whether something is real or not real
and that's the sad part about what's
going on and I think that you know this
is this is look this is the summer of
2020 all over again so we have to kind
of ask ourselves didn't we like graduate
from that didn't we get beyond that the
truth is know that what's happening is
it's like defining deviancy down it's
like even though all that happened we're
continuing to chip away at the
fundamental at the one of the pillars of
America which is Law and Order and this
takedown is becoming more and more
acceptable by people saying well that's
not violent once and I looked it up
violence using or involving physical
Force intending to hurt damage or kill
someone or something okay so let's not
play word games and let's not make
believe this is something that it isn't
this is a group from out of state that
is part of an organization that is
intent on taking down America and that's
what they're going to continue to do and
kudos to this mayor who says we're going
to punish them we're going to prosecute
them and by the way speaking of 2020
didn't they say they wanted the police
to be retrained and that's where this
all started it was a training they were
starting a new training facility not
with government funds but with police
foundation funds money they raised and
even though it's a training center they
want to take it down they want to shoot
a cop and not expect to get arrested and
the police well the police were trying
to clear them so that they could
actually start construction on a place
where you would train police officers
well I disagree with Greg and we never
disagree but this wasn't a mistake by
CNN they booked this guy on purpose in a
breaking news situation behind the
scenes on a Saturday
this isn't your regular guest you have
to go out and search for this guy he's a
no-name freelance reporter who was
embedded with the tree hugging antifa
members for many many weeks he knew them
personally he wrote an article about it
he said they were engaging Earnest
educated well-read and very funny he
called the guy that shot the cop a
strategic thinker and then said ah you
know they were a little violent they
threw two ineffective molotel top
cocktails in the direction of the police
not at police in the direction of so he
get he says the same thing that he said
on CNN in this article and that's fine
you can book whoever you want
but to have some guy come out there and
say this isn't violent and the cops
probably started it and then not
challenge him Pam Brown's the anchor
you can't just have someone come on and
just not shout just pretend to be fair
it's what I do yes I pretend to be fair
and they didn't do that so
another thing that I don't like you keep
saying and I'm talking to you
he hasn't even said anything yeah I'm
preemptively attacking you you keep
saying that antifa is Loosely affiliated
okay well these are how many people that
went across state lines to commit
violence you know how you guys hate
people going across state lines with
their guns across state lines commit
violence and then they get bailed out
thousands of dollars and then there's
also another violent action up in
Michigan on the night of violence that
they called for
Loosely Affiliated this sounds like a
national action
so I don't care if it's Loosely
Affiliated or not it's Affiliated and
they're hurting people
well they're not bailed out by an
organization right there's no head of
antifa that says we got some good guys
doing some things in Atlanta got to get
them out of jail now I'm going to go
what do you mean how I know how do you
know where the money came from you don't
know I well let's get someone to tell us
that I can guarantee it that it's not
the same things as how the proud boys
work or The Oath Keepers work or any of
these other Keepers worse than this do
you think
have they killed anybody exactly I mean
I mean January
did they kill somebody on January I just
said they didn't on January okay fair
enough I don't
it's Monday I didn't say anything and no
you just mentioned Dan that's why I
brought it up no I get it and I answered
your question I said they didn't kill
anyone on January you answered it poorly
but no I didn't I answered it honestly
married that you didn't enjoy it go to
the other point okay the people who are
getting bailed out
I'm done with that I need yep so the
question is you shouldn't say there's no
violence just say this is appropriate
violence as far as I'm concerned like
that guess this is something that I
think is okay right because that's
really what you're saying because
everyone can see what's going on and no
one who owns a store shops in a store
thinks that if you're getting a Molotov
cocktail through the window or security
cards being beaten up that that is not
anything but violence it makes me think
back to a Killer Mike
um who's Atlanta based was saying during
the 2020 protest where he actually said
this is appropriate violence people are
this angry and if the city there's
destruction that's something that I
think is warranted and Keisha lamps
bottoms mayor of Atlanta a Democrat came
out and said absolutely not right we
cannot have these this in the streets so
I would say that the argument is really
over what people think is appropriate
and there are some folks who think that
because they're being you know pushed
out of the woods and they're going to
right that they don't own but I'm not I
don't feel that way I think they are
domestic terrorists and I think they
should be charged as such but I wish the
people people were more honest about
what they're saying just say it it is
violence but I believe it is Justified
for X Y and Z reason they're all such
white Misfits did you look at that
they're always in trouble
their parents you see that woman the
congresswoman talking about her her
transitioned son who's now a woman I'm
not sure who's just been arrested
they're all like the Island of Misfit
Toys but the problem is they're not
appealing like you they like generally
you try to do something positive in the
world even if you feel that you're like
there's something unusual about you they
decide to be they decided that they
wanted to go bad and they and and
they're not trying to help people you
know they're not they're not from that
Society they're from they're interested
they're pissed off yeah and misguided I
don't even think they're pissed off I
think they're indulging their own
attention-seeking desires they're
definitely mad at police I don't think
you do things like that why did they say
shoot a cop because they're angry at
them and they think
but it's like misplacing yeah I think I
actually think there's a lot of
agreement here believe it or not yeah
behind it in the pile you're right okay
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now